you have so many goals to achieve and do
you feel extra pressure because of that
or not no I don't really feel extra
pressure because I mean if you qualify
for the candidates it's well and good
and I probably should at some point you
know really put uh p a fire to my feet
to Target the candidates but at the same
time my mentality is that even if you
qualify for candidates uh with eight
strong players you still have to win it
to really get to the top but uh it's not
like your priority you mean in life to
get to the candidates uh well it's a
good thing to very good thing to qualify
it's like money you know it's good to
have but not exactly my priority